[Music]
you know there is a constant debate that
takes place when looking at the subject
of Technology between people that argue
that technology is part of who we are
and those that believe that technology
is fundamentally unnatural and that it's
a tool that's being used to ultimately
destroy the world I don't fall into that
camp I echo Kevin Kelly's ideas that
stipulate that actually technology is
the real skin of our species
technology is the exterior a ssin of our
nervous system technology is our
extended mind iPhone therefore I am but
think about it technology is literally
the way we turn our mind inside out
right the cognitive philosophers Andy
Clark and David Chalmers described it as
a kind of scaffolding that extends our
thoughts our reach in our vision we are
a tool making animal that has been in a
symbiotic feedback loop with technology
since the beginning of stone tool I mean
think about it once we created stone
tools our jaws shrank once we discover
the fire could cook our flu
making every meal more efficient it
freed up the cognitive real-estate
necessary for the emergence of culture
religion and arts so you might say that
who we are is due to the feedback loops
between us and our tools to the degree
that our tools become extended
appendages that even though they are not
within our biological skin tissue they
are nonetheless a part of our cognitive
arsenal they are a part of us the same
way a nest is a part of a bird and a
spider's web is a part of a spider it is
our extended phenotype it is who we are
it is our termites colony in this
temperature-controlled it is the
extension of our mindedness this is
technology this is the Technium the
seventh kingdom of life
[Music]
Oh